Salut, je finis le rubik's cube !
Parce que y'en a que ça perturbe
quand il est pas fait sur le coté.
On vient de se faire une bonne semaine bien costaud !
Et je vais recadrer cette vidéo c'est n'importe quoi !
ouiiii
c'est pas si mal
Voici aujourd'hui dix astuces mnemotechnique en mode mitraillette
Pour retenir TOUT et surtout n'importe quoi !
ah oui... et j'oubliais générique !
Pour le changement d'heure, 2 fois par an
Vous ne savez jamais ce que vous devez faire avec votre réveil !
Je vais vous le dire !
En OctobRE, on REcule d'une heure
Et en AVril, on AVance d'une heure
AV  d'avril on Avance
OctobRE comme Recule
C'est jamais vraiment en avril ou octobre mais
c'est toujours vers cette période
et avec ça, vous allez arrêter de ne pas savoir !
DEUXIEME
Les accents !
Alors moi j'ai toujours galéré dans ma vie avec les accents aigus, les accents graves
Je sais jamais lequel il fallait mettre !
Il existe une astuce mnémotechnique pour les accents !
Il suffit de vous fier aux sons !
C'est pas mieux ? non...bon
Il suffit que vous gardiez en tête le mot "élève"
Parce que dans "élève" vous avez l'accent aigu et l'accent grave
é-l-è ve
Si vous gardez ce mot en tête, à chaque fois, vous pouvez vous le répéter
et vous savez si vous devez mettre un accent aigu ou un accent grave !
TROIS: Je vous l'ai dit hier, je suis né à La Rochelle
et à La Rochelle, on fait souvent du bateau
et on a une astuce pour retenir Bâbord et Tribord
grâce au mot "batterie"
Vous pensez juste à "Batterie" dans votre tête
"B A T R I", même si vous voulez...
Parce que dans "batterie" Ba c'est à gauche et tri c'est à droite
donc bâbord à gauche et tribord à droite...4ème astuce mnémotechnique ! Mais ça va a une vitesse affolante!
Alors oui ! l'abus d'alcool  ce n'est pas bon pour la santé c'est surtout pas bon pour
la mémoire et pourtant il ya quelque chose
à retenir facilement sur les boissons
anisé grâce à pastis 51! CECI N'EST PAS UN PLACEMENT DE PRODUIT!
pastis 51 nous rappelle
juste par son nom que c'est cinq volumes
d'eau
pour un volume de pastis et le plus
drôle c'est qu'ils sont même pas fait
exprès ils ont juste lancé cette
marque en 1951... l'Arctique.. l'Antartique
Mais c'est où? Qui est en haut? Qui est en bas? c'est
trop compliqué j'ai un truc très
simple
pour me rappeler.. c'est une petite visualisation l'Antarctique il y a plus de lettres
que dans l'Arctique comme il y a plus de lettres
moi dans ma tête il est plus lourd et
comme il est plus lourd il pèse plus lourd
donc il est tout en bas donc
l'antarctique est au sud ! malin le Fabien! ce qui me fait penser au stalagmite
et au stalactite qui monte et
qui descend il y a un "M" dans
stalagmite et il y a un "T" dans stalactite et bien vous vous rappelerez
grâce à ça que les stalagmites ça monte
donc ça part du sol et ça monte
et les stalactites
ça tombe avec le "T" ça Tombe ça Tombe du
plafond vers le bas
du coup parce qu'on tombe rarement vers le haut Ce qui nous amène à la 7ieme Comment est ce qu'on
convertis
un "miles"
en kilomètres qui nous amène à la
7ième quand on convertit des miles en
kilomètre
Hein Marty? C'est très important pour atteindre  les 88miles/H
vous avez juste à retenir
une image; c'est une paire de
ciseaux neuf
même pas la paire en entier juste la moitié
un ciseau neuf quoi, et bien parce que
1 mile est égal à
1 6 0 9 : le zéro fait un peu penser à un "O"
très pratique dans le  milieu nautique
huitième c'est un truc qu'on m'a appris récemment
pour retenir tous les présidents
américains depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale: "la roue est troué essaie la clé
dit johnson qui nie" "Ouais mais la
Ford est sans carter, je ricane"
je vais au premier buisson je fais un clin d'oeil, je vais au 2ième buisson et
Ho!
merveille une belle baraque!"
La roue c'est pour Roosevelt, et trouer c'est pour Truman
essaie pour Eisenhower la
clé
c'est "key" en anglais pour Kennedy Johnson c'est pour Johnson
là c'était assez simple! qui nie pour Nixon, la Ford est sans carter
donc Ford et Carter..  je
ricane c'est un peu plus compliqué
c'est pour Reagan, je vais au 1er buisson c'est pour Bush senior et
je fais un clin d'oeil
clin pour Clinton, je vais au
deuxième buissons donc c'est Bush
juniors, et je décourvre une belle baraque pour Barack Obama
Pour la 9ème on fait un plus simple la 9e c'est par rapport au croissant de lune vous savez quand ça forme
un... espèce de ...
ben de croissant  en fait ça s'appelle un croissant peut-être que vous ne savez pas si c'est
le premier croissant de lune ou le dernier
croissant alors il y a une bonne
astuce pour ça
vous tracez une barre imaginaire dans
votre tête  parce que vous n'aurez jamais d'escabeau assez
grand entre les deux pointes du
croissant, si le croissant est comme ça
vous passez une barre comme  ça entre les deux pointes
vous la tracez mentalement vers le
haut et vers le bas et vous voyez ce que
sa forme si vous pouvez former un "D"
avec c'est que se sera le dernier croissant
de lune et si vous pouvez former un "P"
c'est ce sera le premier croissant de
DIXIEME  et dernière astuccceeeuuu
on a parlé des président américains se serait peut-être bien de parler des
présidents français je vais vous donner
l'ordre de tout les présidents français
de la cinquième république
EH OUAIS!  grâce à la phrase suivante: "Douce patrie gauloise
mélangeant chat solitaire hargneux.." la
c'est un procédé de mémo-technique ou
se base que sur la première
lettre donc: Douce pour De Gaulle,
Patrie pour Pompidou, Gauloise pour Giscard d'
Estaing, Mélangeant pour Mitterrand, chat
pour Chirac, Solitaire pour Sarkozy, Hargneux pour Hollande! Voilà j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura plu ça change un
petit peu ça fait plaisir c'est plus
léger et vous pourriez revenir de temps
en temps quand vous voudrez
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé si ça
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à le faire
savoir en mettant
d'un geste
engagé UN POUCE EN L'AIR! n'oubliez
pas de le faire c'est toujours très important
vous pouvez également
vous abonner à la chaîne avant de
partir puisque le mentale vlog c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
"eeh ouuais"  donc rendez-vous demain à 11h CIAO!